heute in der bildbox Mega Trinkgeld für
diese
Straßenmusikerin bei einem wichtigen
lebensmeilenstein niemals die Freunde
filmen
lassen und Wender x ein pizzaherz bei
dir
bestellt und damit ein herzliches
Willkommen in der
bildbox
[Musik]
[Applaus]
moin wie viel spendet man einer
talentierten Straßenmusikerin 1 € 2 €
sogar 5 Sängerin Jody Lauren aus
glossager England hält 2 p für
angemessen das sind so knapp 2,35 € und
genau diesen Betrag hat s auch schon
voreingestellt auf ihrem Kartenlesegerät
während ein Passant im Hintergrund auf
der Bank ihren Gesang lauscht
[Musik]
nur das dumme Kartenlesegerät gibt bei
der Kälte ständig den Geist auf bis der
Passant von der Bank plötzlich zu Jodi
rüberkommt und mit ihr plaudert und
endlich funktioniert das Gerät auch
wieder nur ist der her mit zund
Trinkgeld nicht ganz
einverstanden
der Unbekannte will selbst den Betrag
eintippen satte 100 P Tipp Jod neuer Fan
in den Kartenleser und ermutig die
21jährige dran zu
bleiben 100 knapp 120 € das ordentlich
und können wir jetzt noch mal kurz
drüber reden dass Straßenmusiker
heutzutage Kartenlesegeräte benutzen
what excuse me wir haben
2024 stell dir vor es ist der schönste
Tag in deinem Leben Schatzi macht dir
endlich den ersehnten Antrag und lässt
das Ganze auch noch von der Freundin
Film der romantischste Moment in deinem
Leben für immer auf Film
gebannt und die heimische Tierwelt
[Musik]
auch ups schon vorbei aber immerhin
liegen sie sich in den Arm sie scheint
ja gesagt zu haben man hätte mir nicht
das Filmen vom Heiratsantrag meines
Freundes anvertrauen sollen schreibt
tiktokerin Mary Dawson zu ihrem
mglüppten filmversuch und 25,6 Millionen
Zuschauer Summe mit ihr
[Musik]
ist er nicht süß also der
Waschbär in einer Woche ist Valentinstag
höchste Zeit Schatzi eine herzpizza zu
schicken der Moment indem ich raffe dass
die Person die zum Valentinstag eine
herzpizza bestellt hat mein Ex ist
kommentiert dieser US pizzalaben seine
spezielle Valentinstags herzpizza und
trifft damit seit mehr als einem Jahr
Millionen zerteilter
[Musik]
käseliebschaften in diesem Sinne Essen
ist eh besser als
Sex man riecht nur danach so ein
bisschen nach ein
veraffe